set 24 hours before the events of the
original Resident Evil comes the
inspirationally titled Resident Evil 0
Resident Evil 0 we follow stars bravo
squad's Rebecca chambers who was an 18
year old medic on her very first mission
with the team Bravo team have been sent
to the Eclair Mountains to investigate a
series of murders linked to cannibalism
as the team arrived the helicopter
suffers engine failure and the team
continued their investigation on foot
Rebecca discovers the Eclipse Express
which is filled with zombies and decides
to explore it
miss chrimbus stumbles across former
lieutenant in the US Marine Corps Billy
Cohen who is our second playable
character why is he a former lieutenant
well Billy has been court-martialed for
killing 23 civilians and was on his way
to be executed when the zombie outbreak
began Billy of course claims he has been
framed and the player must decide over
the course of the game whether they
believe him or not Rebecca and Billy
decide to work together and discover the
zombie outbreak was due to a leech Pike
enemy who could degenerate and reform to
suit the surrounding series antagonist
Albert Wesker and Resident Evil 2
opponent William Birkin are attempting
to cover up the outbreak and plan to
derail and destroy the Eclipse Express
luckily a billion Rebecca put on the
bricks and disembark the train to
discover an abandoned umbrella facility
Rebecca notices a picture of the leech
monster on the wall and through reading
books cutscenes and the occasional
flashback his story is slowly pieced
together dr. James Marcus dr. James
Marcus a founding member of umbrella
after the discovery of the progenitor
virus in 1986
dr. Marcus founded umbrella alongside
Sir Edward Ashford grandfather of Alfred
and Alexia from Cod Veronica and Lord oz
well Spencer who will meet in Resident
Evil 5
dr. Marcus worked on the progenitor
virus to improve the human race but
ultimately did this by creating a bio
organic weapon after 20 years of
research he finally created the t-virus
and is subsequently murdered by fellow
co-founder Oswald Spencer who
paranoid and jealous of Marcus's actions
his two prodigies William Birkin and
Albert Wesker take over the work of dr.
Marcus and we all know how that goes
especially for William Birkin
dr. Marcus now a rotting corpse is
dumped in a sewer along with the queen
leach he was experimenting on over the
course of 10 years the queen leach DNA
reanimate his cadaver merging his
memories and desires for a revenge
against umbrella with the shape-shifting
abilities of the t-virus infused queen
leech right let's get back to our heroes
Rebecca and Billy faced countless
enemies in the ship of monkeys and
spiders and even the tyrant makes an
appearance but the ongoing threat of the
resurrected dr. Marcus keeps the feeling
of peril flowing as if things weren't
difficult enough the dreaded
self-destruction sequence begins and now
there's only minutes until the facility
explodes after a number of battles the
Queen leach begins to overpower dr.
Marcus's influences and evolves into its
final form the Queen leech is seemingly
impervious to bullets but Billy and
Rebecca discover its real weakness
sunlights with the Queen weakened Billy
is able to damage it enough to knock it
back into the underground moments before
the self-destruction sequence ends the
game concludes with Billy being granted
his freedom by Rebecca who ultimately
believes he's innocent
Billy leaves never to be seen again
Rebecca goes on to report that he's deaf
to her superiors but only after she
survives the mansion incident in the
events of the original Resident Evil so
that's it
that's Resident Evil zero in three
minutes if this has been of some help
please subscribe and help our little
channel grow I am Adam from Playstation
grenade and I'll see you next time for
the return of Leon in Resident Evil 4
[Music]